[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir
alors la connaissance la connaissance de
soi la connaissance de soi
moi je me dis que c'est peut-être l'une
des quêtes les plus énigmatiques les
plus profondes et les plus infinie dans
nos parcours de vie n'est-ce pas ouais
et en tant que chanteuse j'avais envie
de vous partager mon expérience parce
que je me suis rendu compte qu'en allant
à la rencontre de mon identité vocale en
cherchant ma voix vo x je me suis rendu
compte que je trouvais ma voix vo lieu
donc j'aime bien jouer sur ce jeu de
mots la voix qui peut sorte hogra fievet
os x v ie on dit souvent de la voie à
calais comme l'empreinte digitale mais
sonore de notre âme et qu'elle reflète
nos parcours de vie notre identité
profonde
aussi quand on chemine avec cet
instrument là qui est le premier
instrument originel c'est comme si on
allait sculpté petit à petit une terre
glaise comme ça intérieur quelque chose
d'argile consultent au fur à mesure du
temps de nos parcours de nos expériences
de vie alors j'avais envie aujourd'hui
de partager un moment assez atypique
avec vous un moment on va tous plongés
en soi pour se met à résonner ensemble à
vibrer ensemble voilà
j'avais plein d'autres choses à dire
mais je les dirai tout à l'heure parce
qu'au fur et à mesure du parcours de vie
c'est aussi les épreuves qui nous
façonnent et jeu vous offrira un champ
de résilience comme ça tout à l'air
alors on va partir à la découverte de ce
monde intérieur parce que j'ai aussi
pris conscience que plus je me connais
c'est moi même et plus je pouvais aller
à la rencontre du monde qui m'entoure
d'une nouvelle façon et c'est comme si
je devenais moi même une sorte de miroir
de reflets plus affûtés qui invite l
autre que je rencontre à lui-même se
rencontrer sa interagit comme ça on
écoute de plus en plus profondément
aussi cette quête de soi elles résonnent
les uns avec les autres et cette quête
de créativité
cette quête d'identité c'est aussi une
invitation quand je chante à permettre à
l'auditeur lui aussi d'aller à la
rencontre de sa propre créativité
c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment devenu
mon mon cheminement ma passion et mon
chemin de vie ma manière d'interagir
avec le monde qui m'entoure par le chant
et par cette manière d'être et de se
reconnaître au fur à mesure du temps
alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
respirer un peu vous laisser résonner et
reprendre contact avec avec votre corps
avec déjà votre propre signature
rythmique votre propre respiration
je vais vous inviter à vous toucher le
bas du ventre n'est pas peur ça fait du
bien à reprendre contact avec vous même
voilà un petit moment de contact
ça fait pas de mal oser prendre soin de
vous faire du bien
alors juste la main ici on va juste
ressentir prendre le temps de laisser
aller la respiration telle qu'elle est
biologiquement comme si vous vous
endormez est juste observé le mouvement
naturel du ventre vous allez vous rendre
compte que le ventre qu'est-ce qui fait
ils gonflent et
voilà ça tombe bien on est près de
l'océan atlantique
vous pouvez visualiser comme un petit
océans avec des vagues qui vont et qui
viennent
votre vente se gonfle ça dégonfle et
pour commencer à rentrer dans la musique
d'ici et maintenant je vous propose de
laisser échapper un petit filet d'air
entre vos lèvres sur le temps
d'expiration du ventre pendant que le
ventre se dégonfle juste on laisse
échapper une petite brise d'air chacun
chacune a son propre rythme
parce qu'on va résonner ensemble les uns
les autres mais en permettant aux
couleurs de chacun chacune de s'extraire
et de s'allier cette petite brise d'air
on va la laisser monter de plus en plus
fort vous allez pouvoir souffler un
petit peu plus fort à chaque fois de
cette petite brise d'air on va
progressivement constitué une forêt
sifflante une tempête pendant que je
parle vous continuez continuez à chaque
expiration un peu plus un peu plus de
souffle
de plus en plus une forêt soufflante
jusqu'à ce que la tempête montrent si ça
peut vous aider vous pouvez aussi lâché
toute la fatigue le stress les mauvaises
pensées toutes les choses dont vous ne
voulez plus en fait on va faire un
espèce de près ménage de printemps qui
arrive en libérant plus en plus voilà
laisser circuler ses terres laisser
entrer le vent comme ça dans votre corps
santé toutes les sensations qui
s'offrent à vous ou est-ce que ça vous
parcours et souffler de plus en plus
forts soyez pas timides allait lâcher je
voudrais que le souffle comme ça remplit
ce jusqu'au plafond de cette salle là
donnez moi toute la puissance toutes vos
tempête intérieure
ça va faire du bien de plus en plus
ouais ça commence à être beau chacun
sera son propre rythme écoutez comment
ça monte
de plus en plus et puis quand vous
sentez que vous êtes arrivé au bout du
processus
je vous proposais un tant d'égoïsme
conscient juste un temps pour prendre
conscience de votre nombril comme s'il y
avait un petit point de chaleur un petit
point lumineux
on va imaginer que c'est le point
d'individualités qui est ici il ya tout
votre unicité tout vous secrets tout
votre parcours de vie juste un temps
pour ressentir ça et vous allez juste
choisir une intention de quelle est la
nouvelle réalité que vous vous offrez
aujourd'hui quelle est l'identité que
vous défendez quelle est l'identité que
vous assumez que vous choisissez d'être
et d'offrir au monde
voilà et cette pensée là on va juste
l'ancré dans le corps grâce à la
vibration du son vous allez allez
toucher votre terre glaise vocale comme
ça votre argile votre son premier et on
va laisser monter ses notes là et ça va
être la chorale instantanée du jour si
vous êtes prêts vous êtes chiche on y va
alors sur le prochain temps d'expiration
du ventre sur le prochain souffle vous
allez laisser maîtres comme ça une
petite bulle de sont pour l'instant
bouche fermée alors on cherche pas à
faire du beau donc il peut y avoir du
grand mail mots des notes imprécises
on s'en fout cherche pas à faire quelque
chose de précis juste vous laisser être
ce qui sort là attention prochaines
expirations partie
chacun sur son propre c'est bien faut
que ça monte un peu plus commencé à
sentir ou est-ce que ça résonne dans le
corps quand vous laisser résonner comme
ça ce qui vient dans quel membre de
votre corps de votre squelette est ce
que ça parcours santé cette dimension-là
physiologique c'est hyper intéressant et
puis laisser grandir c'est notre là
c'est son fait de voir massage comme ça
interne
ça monte de plus en plus loin de plus en
plus fort j'étais à petit votre identité
comme ça vous allez l'offrir l'offrir au
monde
petit à petit vous à les relâcher les
mâchoires leçon va s'ouvrir à
l'extérieur de vous un peu plus fort un
peu plus loin
ouais n'ayez pas peur c'est un temps
pour vous pour vous faire du bien
laisser grandir ses notes la laisser
grandir le son est rempli c'est la salle
et
jacquelin sur sa propre note et
[Musique]
oui
e
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
puis
non
[Musique]
où
c'est cool earth des structures toutes
les formes de son beau parcours et
sortent
thaïs
plus en plus loin
je vous entendre jusque
vous entendre
[Musique]
san remplissez veut voir en piste
encore encore
comme si chacun chacune
[Musique]
e
sa lumière
[Musique]
plus en plus
continuer même sens le bourdon
vous entendre chanter jusqu'à vos
étoiles
encore lui
[Musique]
non
ici présents robert j si c'est tout mais
c'est fini merci c'est très joli
je pense que vous êtes aussi déjà dans
le monde des rêves avec vous vos beaux
fauteuils bien confortable et et toutes
ses idées sur la connaissance
magnifique je vais vous partagez mon
tour ce champ de résilience qui
s'appelle de l'avant pour parler
justement de toujours cette quête de
connaissance de soi et de toutes les
épreuves qui nous façonne qui nous
renforcent qui nous grandissent merci
pour vos voix merci pour votre écoute
[Musique]
et
à vue
füle
e
oh
[Musique]
on
oh
non
[Musique]
je prends la route
j'écoute
toi
suite
encore ce
[Musique]
de nouveau
non
c
hamon
[Musique]
il
je chante la voiture
les filles du thon
je l'aide de zèle
personne
je ne pars enfants
deux hameaux
deux mois
oh
et
[Musique]
oh
de là haut
[Musique]
je vois tout
et
[Musique]
les
m
oh
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
cruel
je
[Musique]
et
c'est
[Applaudissements]